It's like Batman stuff.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie. This will be my full blue
beetle breakdown
aster eggs for the entire movie.
There are a whole bunch of references
to both the DCU and James Gunn's new DCU,
so he felt like he saw a lot of Henry
Cavill Superman References Are Ben
Affleck, Batman
or larger references to the Snyder verse.
You're not mistaken.
The director said that
he put some of those in there
specifically, even though the movie
was intended to be kind of ambiguous
in James Gunn said the character
would come back in his DCU movies.
Don't worry, I'll explain everything.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos. But.
Careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the movie
just because we'll be talking
about everything
starting at the beginning,
working our way through, shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs, WTO moments
as we go along.
The movie has an interesting origin.
Originally, they planned the movie
to just be a streaming movie,
like a much smaller film
with a smaller budget for HBO, Max,
when it still existed when AT&T
still owned Warner Brothers
and DC The movie survived about three
different regime changes
at Warner Brothers because they changed
hands like now they're Warner Brothers
Discovery.
James Gunn came along,
decided to reboot all of DC movies.
But this movie had been made before
he had been hired.
but one of the reasons
why he was so quick to include Jaime Reyes
Blue Beetle in his upcoming DC movies
is because a lot of the references in
the movie are kind of ambiguous,
even though the director has said
otherwise in some of his interviews
This is what set it apart from movies
like The Flash movie,
which had lots of specific references
and scenes that they filmed with
Henry Cavill, Superman, Gal Gadot,
Wonder Woman, Ben Affleck, Batman,
basically all the Snyder verse characters
and stuff that they had to delete
or remove when the movie had been made
because they didn't intend on paying off.
A lot of the post-credits scenes.
So a lot of stuff got changed
for some of the other movies,
including Aquaman two,
which is coming out later this year.
Blue Beetle, however, was a little
more ambiguous, so they just held it.
Survive the transition to the James
Gunn DCU so for the most part,
most of the stuff in the movie
will stay canon in his new DCU movies.
A couple of the jokey references
like Batman and Superman,
some of the things that are going on with
those characters are in this movie.
They probably won't include that stuff
though.
most of you probably remember Blue Beetle
from either the classic comics.
My origin with the character
goes back to the original Infinite crisis
origin of the character.
That's when he debuted in the comics
and got the scarab.
there's only been a couple live action
versions of Jaime Ray, his Blue Beetle
before the Loki debut
during the Smallville episodes
in the final season with Booster Gold.
They're also doing Booster
Gold in the upcoming DC shows.
there was also a Blue Beetle
spinoff TV show they tried to make
for his character back during Smallville
era more than ten years ago.
But at the time they just didn't
have the level of technology in the budget
would have been way too high
the director said the movie
takes inspiration from young Justice
Blue Beetle, like the injustice games
with his combo moves in.
His fights came in writer Dragon Ball
Z with some of the fights, Final Fantasy
seven with his giant sword.
Some of his giant blasters were inspired
by the Megaman games.
lot of people also felt like this
awesome Power Rangers references.
It was supposed to be more like
Kingsman writer.
But Becky G,
who was the voice of Kaiju dog,
the scarab itself
used to be an actual power ranger.
She also has a song in the movie.
According to James Gunn,
Amy Ray is Blue Beetle will come back,
Jenny Cord will come back
and maybe some of the other characters,
but mostly just those two Ted Kord appears
in that first Post-Credits scene.
We'll see if he comes back to
there might be another version.
The character.
I'm not exactly sure who the actor is
in the first post-credits scene.
a lot of people thought that it was Jason
Sudeikis because he would make an awesome
Ted Kord, but that was not Jason Sudeikis
playing Ted Kord in the actual movie.
That was just another actor.
they start the movie with a custom blue
beetle themed DC logo made to look like
the scarab effect when it takes over hosts
like Jaime Reyez later in the movie.
The opening scene is Victoria Kord
finding the scarab in the Arctic.
Later, we find out that Dan Garrett
gave the scarab to Ted 40 years ago
who had received funding from him,
which is right out of the comics
in the comics.
Dan Garrett was the professor of Ted Kord.
we also see their blue
beetle suits later in the movie, too.
but this means that Ted
Kord is the one who hid the scarab
and built these containment devices
in decoys all over the world.
One of the reasons why he supposedly
disappeared in the beginning of the movie
he's been gone for a couple of years
probably has something to do with Victoria
Kord.
the idea is
that he disappeared in the late nineties
and people think that he's dead.
We find that in one of the post-credits
scenes that he's still alive
sending a distress call to his bunker
for Jenny to find.
But it doesn't show where he is.
one of my theories is he also started
to discover the alien origins of the Blue
Beetle scarab and what's going on
with the reach in this part of the reason
why he's gone to ground the reason
why he wasn't around in the comics
when high Mario's got the blue Beetle
Scarab is because he was dead
for at least a little while.
They retcon this later
during the Countdown to Infinite
Crisis Comics, he discovered that
Maxwell Lord plan
to use Checkmate and Brother
AI to take over the world,
who then killed him?
so originally in the comics,
when Jaime Ray has got the scarab,
it was Booster Gold who became the world's
worst mentor to him.
Then Peacemaker and even Guy Gardner
Green Lantern for a while
when he comes back in the upcoming DC TV
shows and movies,
he'll probably cross over on the Booster
Gold TV show, maybe a Green Lantern story.
Nathan Fillion is currently
one of the only ones.
James Gunn is cast
as Guy Gardner for Superman Legacy.
But High May Ray is
won't be in Superman Legacy.
they are doing the Green Lantern HBO TV
show with Hal Jordan and Jon Stewart.
But it's meant to be kind of like true
Detective in the DC Universe set on Earth.
I don't know
if he's going to crossover on to that,
but we'll see
there are only a few brief references
to the other scarabs
in the reach during the movie.
The biggest reference is during
the opening credits.
Writer
Victoria Kord gets the Blue Beetle scare.
It shows the sending all the different
colors of scarabs around the universe,
and it shows the origin of the blue
Beetle scarab damaging itself,
which is also right out of the comics.
all the scarabs are meant
to look a little bit
like the Green Lantern rings
disseminating through the universe.
sort of like the lantern rings
from the entire spectrum of emotions
this sort of gets into the origin
of the reach in why they made the scarabs
in the first place.
thousands of years ago.
The rich conquered plants
the old fashioned way,
their very warlike culture,
the Green Lantern Corps stopped them
and then they were forced
to find other ways to conquer planets.
They developed the scarab tech
as a backdoor way around
the Green Lanterns rule
They'd send scarabs to a world.
And it wait until it achieved a certain
level of technology then find a compatible
host and act like it was a blessing
giving the person superpowers,
but then eventually take over
that person's consciousness in the reach
would use it to conquer the planet,
setting it up for it really easy invasion.
that's
why when they were promoting the movie,
they said
Jaime Ray is is going to be a superhero
whether he wants to be or not,
because basically the blue Beetle scare
takes over a host and does
whatever it wants to use
as a kind of like a finger puppet.
They'd send scarabs to a world.
And it wait until it achieved
a certain level of technology
then find a compatible host and act like
it was a blessing giving the person
superpowers, take over that person's
consciousness in the reach would use it
to conquer the planet, setting it up for
it really easy invasion.
that's
why when they were promoting the movie,
they said
Jaime Ray is is going to be a superhero
whether he wants to be or not,
because basically the blue Beetle scare
takes over a host and does
whatever it wants to use
as a kind of like a finger puppet.
The Easter egg in the opening credits
scene, though,
is that when you see the Blue
Beetle Scarab arriving on Earth,
it bounces through a couple
of different planets and it damages itself
so it doesn't listen to all the reaches
commands all the time, which is why
Hymie Ray
is isn't instantly taken over by the reach
They change a couple of things
about his origin in those opening credits,
making it seem like ancient
Latin American cultures
were able to use it in
it bonded with people in ancient times,
in the comics and in the movie,
it was Dan Garrett who initially found
the scarab beetle on an archeology dig,
then gave it to his student, Ted Kord,
both of whom took the mantle of Blue
Beetle and became superpowers.
But neither one being able
to unlock the full potential of the scarab
The car Packs villain is originally a Dan
Garrett Blue Beetle villain
who then later turned into a Ted Kord
silver Age villain in the comics.
He got his suit from Ted Cord's uncle's
secret lab on Pogo Island,
which is a location they use in the movie.
There are a couple Easter eggs
with this origin story.
His consciousness
had been transferred into the suit,
allowing him a form of immortality.
In the movie is more of like a cyborg
symbiotic relationship,
kind of like the blue
beetle scarab in blue Beetle himself
The movie combines him
with The Omen in Brother
I's storyline from Infinite Crisis,
which is where Jaime Ray is.
Blue Beetle got his origin story,
in the comics, brother.
I was an advanced A.I.
satellite Batman
created to help defend the world
more efficiently monitoring crime
all over the globe.
The A.I. went rogue.
Turned villain is Hijacking Checkmates
Omak Project, the one man Army Corps
and almost took over the planet,
killing heroes and villains
alike as Batman had programed
the satellite with everyone's weaknesses.
High May res
became the blue beetle in helps
the other Justice League characters
and heroes destroy the satellite.
The movie has court industries under
Victoria Corps developed the iMac project.
When they download the software
from the Blue Beetle Scarab,
they used to finish the project.
And she references how the software itself
is the most important part of it.
That's more of the Brother AI Easter egg,
like the software on her phone.
there's also another brother
Easter egg on the poster too, Jaime
Ray, his bedroom,
just a reference to his comic book origin.
Susan Sarandon's
Victoria Cord is from the comics.
She's Ted Cord's evil sister.
She was only featured
briefly, though during the movie.
She also says the company has
Promethean mines elsewhere in the world.
That's like the vibranium or adamantium
of DC Comics is the special metal
that Deathstroke swords
are made of during the opening credits,
they show TED cause history as Blue Beetle
being a superhero in the eighties
and nineties with his Batman
mobile technology, like the bug ship,
which is right out of the comics
and they use later in the movie
the reference to him Fighting fire
Fist was the villain from Ted Cordes,
the very first issue in his solo comic
when he debuted as the only blue beetle
from Volume six. Number one in 1986.
in the context of the movie
this is meant to be his first appearance
in universe as the character.
But in the comics Dan
Garrett was the blue beetle
for a long time through Volume five
and they debuted the Ted Kord
character back in 1966.
just that Dan Garrett
didn't wind up dying in Ted Gordon
become the only blue beetle
until much, much later.
One of the other changes the movie makes
is to say that Jaime Arraez and Ted Kord
come from Palmyra City, which is kind of
like the DC Universe version of Florida.
Palmer is a real place in DC
Comics, though it's not meant to be like
a Ray Palmer Atom reference Originally,
he was from El Paso, Texas.
There is an E Street
for this in the movie.
The family lives on El Paso Street.
In the movie.
He's much older than comic book
Hymie Ray is.
Originally, he got the scarab
when he was still a teenager in the movie.
He just finished college
after attending Gotham University.
He also wears a Gotham Law sweatshirt,
implying that he's pre-law
and wants to go back to Gotham
for his law degree someday.
they also make a lot of Batman jokes
and references later in the movie,
referencing other Justice League heroes
just in general, George Lopez.
His uncle calls
Batman a fascist, mostly because he's
so rich and doesn't have a sense of humor
because they're talking about Ted Kord
being funny in the comics.
His uncle is also meant to be like
a crazy conspiracy theorist,
kind of like peacemaker, like basically
the same vibe of the character,
a little bit nutso.
But in the context of Blue Beetle,
his uncle is a tech genius.
they use this as a running gag
during the Peacemaker series, too,
where he makes fun
of all the different Justice League
heroes.
the other major Batman
joke reference is on the radio.
There's a broadcast in Spanish
that they're listening to in.
The announcer reveals that Bruce Wayne
has just purchased a social media
platform, which is more of a real life
reference to Elon Musk buying Twitter
that will probably not
be Canon in James Gunn's new DCU movies.
Don't think Batman is going to be owning
any social media platforms.
there are a bunch of wider DC references
in the city landscape of the buildings.
There's an ACE Chemical building
from the Batman comics, the Batman movies,
Elex Corp Building for Superman.
later in the movie.
They also reference Superman,
the Flash, Green Lantern,
Generally,
the director said all the Justice League
characters were meant to be ambiguous,
that they could be
any versions of those characters,
like the Snyder verse
or the more modern DCU films that James
Gunn is doing, So it's not necessarily
Henry Cavill Superman or Ezra Miller Flash
or Ben Affleck, Batman.
But he did say, like the director did say
he specifically wanted references
to Zack Snyder's Man of Steel movie
because he was such a big Zack Snyder fan.
So technically
there are some DCU references
Zack Snyder also came out in real life
in support of the movie,
which is really cool.
when they're watching the news.
The broadcast is from Gibbs,
which is also from the comics.
It stands for a Galaxy broadcasting system
which is run by Morgan Edge
from the Superman Comics.
The station was also featured
in the Man of Steel movie Aquaman,
the Suicide Squad movie
and the Shazam movies, Most of his family
members are based on comic book versions
of the characters, with a few additions.
His father survives in the comics,
but they don't
really participate in his adventures
the same way.
we meet Jennie Cord.
She's not from the comics in universes
meant to be kind of like a Bulma Dragon
Ball type of character
running capsule Corp
like a female Iron Man with a bunch of
cool tech that everyone uses.
that's basically the arc for her
at the end of the movie.
Like she ends up running Cord Industries
after Victoria Kau dies in basically
ending their production of weapons
like Iron Man did with Stark Industries
during the first Iron Man movie.
RV, Gwen plays sort of like a scientist
version of Otis from the Christopher Reeve
Superman movies to Victoria
Cords. Lex Luther.
He winds up
turning good at the end of the movie
to when she steals the scarab
she puts it in a big belly burger box.
Big belly burger is a big chain.
And DC Comics that have been featured
a ton of times in the DC TV shows
and movies, most prominently
in the arrowverse, like multiple shows.
Arrow Flash use it all the time
when he gets the scarab in the comics.
They didn't go full Iron Man
Jarvis with the Scarabs consciousness,
like in the movie, treats it
more like a DC version of Jarvis, though.
Like it is a direct reference to Iron Man
when they infiltrate court industries
to get TED cords wired
so they can get into his secret base,
one of the TV shows
that they use to distract the guards is
take it from the stop motion
animated version of El Chapo in Colorado.
there's a longer version of this that they
play in the second Post-Credits scene.
The character debuted in the early 1970s
on another TV show was huge in Latin
American countries
and eventually got his own spin off
show that ran for years
in the context, the movie is also meant
to be a reference to Jaime.
Rey is becoming a Latin American
superhero.
There are a bunch of you
on my post-credits scene video
that commented that you actually grew up
watching the character.
there even some special promotions
for the movie that feature new animation
with the character in Blue Beetle,
in the same style of the original TV show.
the statue in the yard
is meant to be of Ted Cord's grandfather
who founded the company Kord Industries,
And when Blue Beetle starts his fight
with car parks for the first time,
most of their fighters in general
are meant to be a reference to Superman's
Zod fight in Man of Steel.
Along with the move from injustice
to some of Caiman Ryder
his sword is supposed to be inspired
by the Final Fantasy sword
and then the Blaster
is from the Megaman Games.
some of the later fights turn into Dragon
Ball references with Goku versus Vegeta.
And also when Goku went Super Saiyan
for the first time as Blue Beetle powers
up in the movie a few times
the reason why all of Ted Cord's take
looks like it's stuck from the eighties
and nineties is
because it was the late nineties
when he disappeared.
George Lopez joking that he wasn't
as good as Superman or the other Justice
League superheroes
like The Flash or Batman.
They're making jokes about his tech
not always working is also right
out of the comics.
They always joked about TED Courts tech
not being that great, him
just being kind of like a B-list
superhero.
but he always had a sense of humor,
which is a reference to his crossovers
with booster gold, just like the tone
in general of the classic Blue
Beetle Comics generally
way wackier than the other DC heroes.
the blue beetle bug ship is right
out of the comics and when they're
grabbing weapons I may sister use the
any as power glove as a weapon.
One of Jennifer's devices
is a classic game boy that has a worm
light Pogo Island in the comics was also
where Ted Cord's uncle had a secret base
and where car parks got his origin
in the comics.
It's also where Dan Gilbert wound up dying
in the comics to lot of people felt like
this scene of Hymie
raised in the afterlife on
the edge of death
is basically the same type of scene
as Rocket in Guardians of the Galaxy
three.
Obviously, the director did not base it
on Guardians of the Galaxy three,
but is basically the same vibe with them
both telling the characters
that it wasn't their time yet.
during the first Post-Credits scene,
there's a signal coming from inside
Ted Cordes Blue beetle cape
like his back cape, so to speak.
The song all out of Love Place
because every time they go into the cave,
there's always some 80 song that plays
the signal is coming from him and Ted Kord
There's a bunch of satellite signals
that bounce around like all these systems
activated on the computer
in this fuzzy broadcast from him.
Like a message says Tell my daughter Jenny
court that her father is still alive.
Ted Kord is still alive.
while that scene plays, the camera
zooms in on that third mannequin.
This black with a pillow tied around it.
That's meant to represent Jenny Cord
Eventually.
I think the idea was
when she was younger
and she would visit the cave with Ted Kord
TED Court had always intended for her
to get her own suit
and was going to make it
and put on their mannequin
like the mannequin was meant
to represent her eventual suit
when she grew big enough,
the second Post-Credits scene
is just a longer version of that animated
Latin American TV show El Chapo
in Colorado that they use
to distract the court industrys guards
at the end of the clip, you hear George
Lopez's voice and he's kicking
like a giant machine saying, That's sexy.
It's probably dialog
taken from earlier in the movie
when he was distracting the guards
with his machine
and had to kick it
a bunch of times to get it to work.
Let me know where you want the character
to crossover
in future DC movies and shows,
maybe on the Booster Gold TV show,
maybe the Green Lantern series,
maybe Peacemaker Season two,
but at least the next Justice League
movie.
He's not going to be in Superman legacy,
though.
let me know in the comments
if you spotted any of their Easter eggs
or references in the movie
that I didn't talk about in the video.
There are a ton of very specific
references,
particularly to Latin American culture.
big reminder is that next week
Asoka episodes start on Tuesday.
My videos will post every week
just like normal.
click here for my Blue Beetle
post-credit scene
video and click here
for that teaser for the new version.
The Justice League in the new version
of Green Lantern with Nathan Fillion.
Thank you so much for watching,
everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!